you say let's get your 10-year plan
let's work on your three-year plan and
your one year let's set benchmarks
that's goal setting it sounds simple mr
president but it's not happening in our
communities enough the second portion
that mr bryant laid out was building
bridges that's about social capital
so everybody doesn't know that they can
call their elected official when they
have issues everybody doesn't understand
uh my mother's used to say um show me
your friends
and i'll show you where you're going
i'll show you where you're going to end
up so we really focus on the networks
and net worth of those networks the last
part i think is the most important
content management because we have to
get young people who have access to guns
who don't have access to spaces and
places to thrive we have to get them to
understand the power of their minds that
there's personal responsibility that
they have to take that thoughts become
things
so sometimes we talk to young people
about how much time they spend listening
to certain music or going to certain
movies or watching certain shows just so
we can keep a peg on what are you
feeding your mind and those are the
three parts of the sgp tool
any questions before we talk to our gang
specialist mr president oh i've done a
lot of work in this journey but i want
to hear it more okay all right so mr
campbell gang specialist community
liaison supervisor peace how are you
doing
man
you're doing all right
but my name is emmanuel campbell and my
role at ccd is bring groups of people
that usually don't be together together
what that entails is peace treaties
um
mediation and understanding we have a
special group within our organizations
called cls which stands for community
liaison now their job is to go into
different inner city communities and
build relationships throughout new york
city in new york state build
relationships get intel grab data and
bring it back to our organization so we
can sit down and debrief and see how we
can go into these rural areas in the
inner city communities
and
provide the best support
now
hold on one second on that point that's
not an everybody job mr president
everybody can't be a community zone you
got to be born with a gift you got to
have a certain type of you have to know
how to be in a room
and just kind of you know do things
without talking sometimes you got to be
like a james bond kind of character
so so the training is about diplomacy a
community liaison and we created that
position to work around the city of new
york
so that you can say you know what i'm
not i'm here but i'm not here to you
know i'm here to support quietly
right a community liaison knows how to
be in places that are very tricky and
hairy and not escalate situations
so we see people that have that that
kind of innate ability but we also try
to work on them with their skill sets to
develop it a little more you like to be
an ambassador yeah
that's what he is
that's what it is yeah and just to i
don't want to embarrass the brother so
woodside and queensbridge houses have a
rivalry that goes back
it's like the the montagues and the
capitalists they don't even know
sometimes why they're shooting and
killing each other and it just so
happens mr campbell's from
a team in woodside right we're not going
to say a gang but a team in one side
that had beef with teams and
and so him coming on the team they said
no way don't do that campaign do not
bring someone from that side to this
side and he's been probably one of the
most important hires we've ever made
because he's the bridge he has that
skill set so whether we're in harlem but
i should say cool or if we're in the
bronx with groups up there this
gentleman knows how to navigate and he
has the influence and credibility to get
us peace agreements
and once you're in a state of peace
then we can talk now we can kind of sort
through what is this about is taking
another life gonna end this situation or
just keep us going so
very crucial to our work our human
justice work is the community liaison
ambassador as you said
i used to have a close friend who was a
hell of a
national basketball player
and he used to say you got to know how
to know
going to know how to know
i can walk you into the
library of congress you know how to read
the card catalog is of no value to you
you guys know how to know
yeah
thank you sir i appreciate this let's
let's go this way if you wouldn't mind
mr president we'll talk about education
we are in ps 111
um and we're very happy and fortunate to
be here this is a phenomenal place of
learning
you know and i've heard you speak in the
in the not so distant past about some of
the disparities
in education especially in communities
of color health disparities and others
but specifically in education
well when you get leadership
in a school
that immediately buys into
this human justice approach to dealing
with conflict
i'm gonna let principal dragon describe
our relationship over the past few years
and what we've been able to accomplish
just want to say again our mayor is here
and part of the success we know that's
gonna happen moving forward in new york
city is because before this gentleman
was elected he said okay bain i get it
and he got it
he's one of the people that comes out
with us on deployments sees it firsthand
kind of like you're doing here today
right but it's important when leadership
right away not six seven eight years
later but right away
gets it and principal jagging can
describe what the outcomes look like
when that happens that's one question
sure what are the grades here
i'm sorry what are the ages and this is
a community school pre-k to eight pre-k
yes so welcome
and mr president as you know education
is the foundation for success it builds
confidence it creates character and it
sets the foundation for learning and we
have the greatest teachers here that are
imparting that knowledge on our children
we have a process approximately 300
scholars here and i know them all with
the collaboration with k bane
and ccd we have worked to bring the
resources
from the community inside of our school
and we have to recognize as leaders our
role is to make more leaders and that
only happens when we step into the
community i can tell you the impact of
when i walk into queensbridge it's
similar to what you said with my cell
phone
and the children see me in their
neighborhoods and they're like oh that's
miss jack and when i come back to school
that builds trust and confidence and
education breaks down those barriers but
that can only happen when we're careful
and we bring those resources right into
school in our school i'm very happy to
say that community capacity development
they're here every day through
accomplished mediation supporting our
dismissal
we understand that's a critical part of
the instructional day we have the best
teachers teaching i can hear my
superintendent dr
philip compostel saying build community
as a leader i recognize very early in my
principalship that community
partnerships is the way to go we have
our scholars here grades one to four
they all have bank accounts they need to
understand that education provides them
choice
what better place to begin that having
money for college right here with nyc
kids rise and i'm proud to say that that
started right here in community school
education district 30 under the
leadership of our superintendent the
support of our partners
and as a principal we've learned how to
manage our partnerships and bring them
in our scholars receive free dental
in the school our scholars also have a
pantry the parents can shop for food
in the school when they need glasses
vision you know they're getting
headaches we provide it to them free of
charge in the school so what we've done
as a community as a team we've taken
away the barriers because we can have
the best teachers the best principles
but learning will not happen
learning cannot happen when we're faced
with those barriers when i'm hungry
my teeth hurts i have a headache when i
can have people working with me and
understanding that goal and that
challenge and how real it is
and we can eliminate that learning can
happen and i see my children building
confidence they can speak they can
articulate they can use their words i
want to thank you for that with the
mediation getting the the power of
language
and one of our instructional focus here
is making thinking visible and we do
that through discussion and i always
tell them when you can choose when you
can choose where you live
when you can choose where you want to go
for higher education when you can choose
who you speak for when you can choose
who you partner with
things become so much better and so
enlightened and as a principal as an
educator
as a teacher i i recognize the
importance of doing that with our
teachers
doing that with our partnerships
bringing in robotics having financial
literacy the critical thinking skills
all of that necessary to make good
humans violence will stop yes it starts
here school is magical this is where we
learn this is where the imagination can
grow this is where we have fun um we are
a community school of multimedia
communication and arts that is led by
our positive behavior director mr murray
who supports us that is also supported
by our assistant principal miss hamm who
focuses on vocabulary and leadership
with our teachers and scholars i have an
amazing data specialist that has tracked
our impact throughout the years as a
school we went from being persistently
dangerous to a school in good standing
and that happens with the power of
partners can you say that again as the
school went from persistently dangerous
when i was given the privilege of
becoming the principal of the jewel of
long island city this school was
persistently dangerous mr president how
is that defined consistently dangerous
so this the city new york city had a
marker with a radar
index
the violence index
when i took over the school the index
was 3.2
persistently dangerous at that time was
1.5
so i was more than double
the following year we went down to 2.0
still persistently dangerous so i'm
bearing that weight and i'm thinking
what can i do
to remove that
stain
to get our children learning to get them
wanting to be here
the third year we went down to 0.9
no longer persistently dangerous
here comes kay being helping us with
that tell me what
constitutes
pretty dangerous you mean fights in
school kids with guns in schools in
school
fights in schools
children hurting each other children
getting injured looking differently than
they came in and leaving looking another
way
it makes the school different
um now when we come in it's a happy
place
children are smiling i get hugs and
kisses i can't tell you the little ones
are at my ankles
the big ones are over here um just a
little story of one of my eighth grade
scholars she's now the president of our
scholar government
she's been here the entire time with me
when we first got to know each other she
was little i think she was in second
grade she wouldn't speak very shy
through the years of us being together
working with the partners seeing the
familiar faces in the school her
confidence has built now she's making
choices she campaigned in the school she
put up her signs she gave out treats she
ran a very solid campaign
and was elected and she takes her
position very seriously and she
advocates for the scholars in our school
she tells me what's needed but that
happened because of our work
she has choices what kind of
participation do you have from parents
we have we created those structures so
we made it so that we communicate with
the parents in their language so they
have different opportunities because we
recognize that different parents have
different needs so we have participation
in morning with our principal's
breakfast that we host
we have academic parents who come to our
academic parent teacher teams where we
share the data the academic take data do
they show up
they come so here's the thing mr
president we have parents who come
to the
events that are celebratory the children
are singing and dancing because we are
art school then we have the academic
parents that come in we would like more
participation of course
and we need that help we have an old
expression i come from don't kid a kid
yeah i know a lot about schools yeah
and one of the most difficult things in
schools
where in fact you were persistently
dangerous or not
is the lack of participation of the
parents
and the parents many times are
don't have the confidence
to even be seen or be involved at all
because they can't read or they can't
write or they have a background whether
they have a drug problem or whatever
that's why i ask the question because i
don't know
of a school
that in fact is doing well that does not
have more parent participation
that's why i asked the question i'm not
trying to be critical i'm just trying to
understand it and i appreciate i think
what what you're saying raises the fact
that there's an intersectionality around
inequity so education
when done wrong is violence when health
needs are not met in a community that's
a form of violence it contributes to the
violence and so that's why it's
important in a holistic approach that we
call healing justice human justice work
we consider food apartheid what food do
people have access to that is something
that contributes to violence so when
students don't feel safe
there is no learning the sgp the tool
that we spoke about mr president is
about taking the individual from
survival mode mentality
survival fight flight freeze into one of
creation where an individual be the
student being an adult be it a gang
member can start to design and define
reality for themselves and so those are
the type of tools and approaches that we
use it's worked here
it's worked in baltimore maryland
recently we got a report we did some
training there and uh what county were
we in
in edison county in baltimore maryland
365 days no shooting no killing because
we dealt with the mentality we dealt
with the food we dealt with all these
factors that once upon a time they said
was everything under the sun approach
they said you guys are trying to go
after everything but people are
multi-layered three-dimensional so we
can't just talk about violence and not
talk about students feeling safe in
schools
we can't talk about violence and not
talk about chemical misuse or dependency
on substances we have to talk about all
of these things
simultaneously if we're going to stop
violence from happening in our cities
around the country and what's being done
here with our school with our families
and being replicated in the district in
our community areas needs to be
replicated across the country for this
to work absolutely i think i think we
got a great example and a model for the
nation here um if you win my brother
cobb i want to introduce martin cava
operations manager um to talk a little
bit about our pillars yeah youth
development absolutely some of the major
blessings to you mr president peace and
blessings man
uh
we're lucky that
that the crisis management system that
we speak about
kate baine is one of the core architects
from his mentor's work in the 90s and
restorative justice
to his work when he was on the city
council drafting the legislation that
eventually became the crisis management
system
there's three parts to it we spoke about
the anti-gun violence piece
there's also a wraparound services piece
where we provide
referrals mental health education
and the third piece is what we're here
today it's called school mediation
[Music]
the same staff that we deployed
out in those streets we're going to stop
the fights is the stuff that we bring in
here to prevent the fights
the same staff that's out there stopping
the conflict
is the same staff that we bring into
these schools
to prevent conflicts
and the way we do it is we have this
thing called five pillars the five
pillars exactly this financial literacy
arts and culture critical thinking
conflict resolution and health and
wellness all of our programs activities
are driven on those five pills
and subliminally to k's point they go
back
to human rights
human development and human justice so
we're being creative in our approach and
instilling these values in our youth
because the ultimate goal is we want
human rights human development human
justice for them
and those are the foundations for
community partnerships the community
work that's being done in school and the
rapid wrap around services are essential
in schools
parents need to know that they can come
here and just get it and have that worry
eliminated so learning can happen
the one thing that i've observed over
the years is that
the more you have the parents involved
the better the shot the less you have
them involved
the harder the shot
because they may come
out of an environment during the day
that you're providing
if they go home
and mom or dad is in real trouble
and they they have real truck real
problems one of the things that
surprised me
as we've done and all the congressmen
and senators behind me
behind you
know that uh
we found that if you there's extensive
studies done if you send a
three-year-old and a four-year-old no
matter what background they come from no
matter how
dysfunctional the home
you send that child to school not to day
care to school
you increase by somewhere between 48 and
56 the chance that they'll go all the
way through all 12 years of school
and go on beyond that right
but it is uh because up to that time
anyway that's why i asked so much about
the parent involvement uh
sounds like that some legislation built
back better
that was fascinating
yeah but yeah but yes and no i mean this
is this is even more basic than that
what i'm trying to get at is that uh
um
it is
difficult
to
for a
child no matter what circumstance
they're in
for
10 hours a day when they leave home and
go to school and go back
if they go back to a totally
dysfunctional system
in their home
and so that's why i'm asking you haven't
talked at all about the home
and what impact that has on what you're
doing
because in most in the neighborhood
i used to work in a neighborhood that
was in the projects for years
and uh you could tell
what in fact was likely to be the shot
the kid you were working with
if it based on the home situation there
is right
and that's why i asked about but you've
never once mentioned parents so outreach
workers right we talked about community
liaisons as a position in what they do
how they make peace agreements we have
what's called outreach workers and
violence interrupters an outreach worker
becomes semi-guardian a lot of times to
young people so our outreach workers
will be the ones who will pick up young
people take them from the school if
there's no food at home then we have a
team that makes sure that those basic
human needs are being met many times
young people will stay in our offices in
our centers in our spaces well into the
wee hours of the night we're the ones
that say let's do some homework with you
here because your lights are not on at
home so there is a component of the
model and every outreach worker is
assigned to a case of 10 to 15 young
people most of the time these young
people are high risk there are certain
things that we check off to say this is
a high-risk young person for example you
have just been involved in the criminal
justice system and you're returning
another example you have access to a
firearm another example what we check
off the deemed somewhat high risk
is that you're involved in a street
organization or gang but these are
you